now returning to the refugee crisis and
specifically what's being done in
Britain to prepare for migrants when
they arrive while Catherine Gladwell is
the director of the refugee support
network out she joins me now and a very
good afternoon to you Catherine well
first of all tell me about the number of
offers I know they've been flooding in a
people who are willing to to house
refugees yeah absolutely this week we've
seen a unprecedented number of people
get in touch with our charity we've had
people offering rooms we've had people
offering entire houses we've had people
offering their time we even had six year
old children offering their pocket money
and their view any idea how specifically
it will work while waiting to hear from
the Prime Minister of course later this
afternoon but but is that the route that
you think it will go the local
authorities will then accept offers from
people to have some of the refugees in
their own homes I think what's clear is
that whatever happens we need a clear
system that can make sure that people
are housed safely in a lot of these
cases we're talking about children and
you obviously can't just put a child in
a house there needs to be a proper
system to make sure that people are
trained and that this happens properly I
mean what we're saying to people is that
if you don't have a room if there isn't
a system up and running where you can
offer accommodation there are other
things that you can do you can still
make a difference of course I mean lots
of things in terms of contributions that
but I mean people will we need to be
aware weren't they this was from the
head of the local government association
saying well you know for people seeking
asylum it can take several years for the
process to be gone through so you have
to be prepared for that kind of length
of time you do and it is a long process
and we've been supporting refugee
children in this country for several
years and one of the things that we see
is that what happens in that time when
people are waiting is incredibly
important and you can imagine for
children one of the most important
things is that we actually take that
opportunity to invest in their education
at 13 million children have had their
education destroyed by the conflict in
Syria and in North Africa and when they
arrived here they start to say I want to
use education to put the pieces of my
life back together and we have an
opportunity to enable them to do that
but of course as we know a lot of strain
on school places and things like that
beginning of a school year at this very
moment
it's a question of resourcing as well
another thing you'll be wanting to hear
from the Prime Minister that local
authorities will want to hear about
resources going into things like
education absolutely housing and medical
help absolutely and I think this is the
time when the statutory sector the
government and the voluntary sector
really need to be able to work together
to provide the resources that people
need so taking the example of education
that you mentioned we work with a large
number of volunteer mentors who will
support teachers support social workers
to help individual children progress in
their education and that's the type of
support that we could see set up across
a number of different sectors whether
it's health whether it's education and
to respond to this need what do you
think about the the numbers involved
here you know if it's set 10,000 even if
its twenty thousand there are millions
of people just in Syria alone on our
outside Syria who've been affected there
are many more from other countries
they're at rest sudan just it just to
name a few do you think Britain should
be doing more you're right this is
absolutely a global crisis and our
attention right now is on Syria but it's
easy to forget some of the longer crises
like what's happening in the Democratic
Republic of Congo for example and I
think what we need is a three-pronged
approach that will look at durable
solutions in the long term so looking at
what can be done to build peace in those
regions what can be done to increase
resources in the intermediate host
countries so places like Jordan Lebanon
Turkey that are taking the bulk of the
refugees but then also there's immediate
needs on our doorstep as well and we've
got a responsibility to look I mean when
they do come into the European Union it
doesn't look as if Britain is doing as
much all it is an absolute fact not just
about looks is not doing as much as
places like Germany or Sweden the
response in Germany has been absolutely
phenomenal over the last couple of weeks
and you're right we can't have a
situation where the burden of this
crisis was entirely on just a couple of
European countries we need a shared
response and we need the UK to get
involved in that okay very good to talk
to Catherine glad well thank you very
much